SPEAKER: It's
important to protect
your API from unauthorized
access, and one way to do this
is with API keys.
And so in this
episode, we will cover
how to create an API proxy
that requires an API key,
and then also how to
create an API product,
how to add a developer,
how to register an app
and then call your
API with an API key.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When an app makes a request
to an API proxy that
is configured to
verify an API key,
the app must supply a valid key.
At runtime, the
Verify API Key policy
checks that the
supplied API key is,
one, valid, hasn't been
revoked, and matches the API
key for the API
product that exposes
the requested resources.
If the key is valid,
the request is allowed.
If the key is
invalid, the request
results in an
authorization failure.
So let's first start
off by creating a proxy.
Visit apigee.google.com.
Next, click Develop,
API Proxies, Create New.
This is the Build
a Proxy wizard.
Select Reverse Proxy, which
is the most common, FYI.
Enter the following
values like this.
Click Next.
On the Common Policies
page, select API Key.
This option automatically adds
two policies to your API proxy.
Click Next.
On the Summary page, select the
Optional Deployment checkbox
for your environment.
Next, click Create and Deploy.
And finally, select
Edit Proxy to view
the overview of the API proxy.
From here, you can view the
deployment status, which takes
a few seconds to complete.
To view the policies that
were added by the wizard,
let's select the Develop tab.
You'll see that
two policies have
been added to the proxy request
proof flow of the API proxy.
One is Verify API
Key, which checks
the API call to make sure
a valid API is present,
sent as a parameter.
The second is a
Remove Query Param API
Key, which is an assigned
message policy that
removes the API key after it's
checked so that it doesn't
get exposed unnecessarily.
Click the Verify API Key
Policy icon in the flow view
and look at the policy's XML
configuration in the lower code
view.
The API Key element
tells the policy
where it should look for the
API key when the call is made.
By default, it looks for the
key as a query parameter called
APIKey in the HTTP request.
The name APIKey is not special.
It can be any property
that contains the API key.
Next, let's try to call the API.
First, lets directly
access the target.
In a web browser, go to
the following address--
mocktarget.apigee.net.
This is a target service
the API proxy is configured
to forward requests to.
You should get this successful
response, "hello guest."
Now let's make a
call to the API proxy
to see how it's being
protected by the policies.
We will make a
curl command using
the external
internet-facing host name.
If you do not have one set up,
I have included instructions
in this video's description.
Note that in my
case, the external IP
provided by the
external load balancer
is configured with a
DNS registered hostname.
We can call the API using curl
and a command line terminal,
such as the Cloud Shell from
your Google Cloud project
at console.google.com.
Because of the Verify
API Key policy,
you get the following
error response
since it did not
pass a valid API key.
If we didn't
configure that policy,
you would get the same
successful response
we saw before.
Now close your Cloud terminal.
[? great, ?] so now
let's get an API key.
First, we'll create
an API product
by returning to the Apigee
console and select Publish, API
Products.
And click on the +API Product.
Enter the product details
for your API product.
First, an internal name--
and note you cannot
use special characters.
And once created, you
cannot change it later.
Next, enter the
display name, which
can use special characters.
Or you can let it default to the
name which is used in the UI,
and you can edit it at any time.
Next, add a description
of your API product.
Then check the box to
have it allow access
to your eval environment,
and change the access
level to Public.
Also check the box to
Automatically Approve Access
Requests.
You can leave Quota and the
Allowed OAuth Scopes unfilled
for now.
Next, scroll down a bit to the
API resources section and click
Plus, then select the API
proxy you just created,
then click Add.
In the Path section, click Add
a Path and enter a single slash.
Click Save.
Next we're going to simulate the
workflow of a developer signing
up to use your APIs.
A developer will have one or
more apps that call your APIs,
and each app gets
a unique API key.
This gives you, the API
provider, more granular control
over access to your APIs
and more granular reporting
on API traffic by app.
So let's create a developer
by selecting Publish,
Developers in the left
menu, and click +Developer,
and enter the following in
the New Developer window,
and click Create.
Now let's register an app
by selecting Publish, Apps,
and click +App.
Enter the following data in
the New Developer App window.
Click the Developer
box to select
a developer you just created.
Then in the Credential
section, ensure Never
is selected so that the
credentials for this app
never expire.
Next, click Add
product and select
the product you just created.
And finally, click Create.
Now let's get the API key by
clicking Show in the Key field.
You can access this page later
by going to Publish, Apps,
and selecting your app.
Notice that the key is
associated with the product
you created.
Select and copy
the key, which you
will paste as a query parameter
using the documentation's
template, and ensure
there are no extra spaces.
Next, open your Cloud
terminal once again
and paste this curl document.
And now when you
call the API proxy,
you will get "Hello,
Guest" as a response.
Congratulations.
You've created an API
proxy and protected it
by requiring that a valid API
key be included in the call.
However, note it's
a good practice
to pass the API key
in a header rather
than in a query parameter.
The reason is because
headers do not
appear in the browser
history or network
logs, which could present
a possible security risk.
And so I have linked
instructions on how to do so.
And there you have it--
a quick walk-through
on how to protect your API
from unauthorized access.
And friends, if you found
this episode helpful,
you can click Like or
subscribe to the channel.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]